We now have two things added together. We have 4 x times the quantity 2 x plus
5, added to 3 times the quantity 2 x plus 5. Between these two terms, we have a
common factor of 2 x plus 5, so we can start by pulling that outside. And then,
we can multiply that, and then we can rate the things that it multiplies. 4 x
plus 3. So the final factored form of 8 x squared plus 26 x plus 15 is just this
expression, the quantity 2 x plus 5 times the quantity 4 x plus 3. Awesome.
Let's check that just to make sure. We multiply 2 x by each of these terms, and
then we multiply 5 by each of these terms. All we need to do now is add like
terms, and voila, we have verified that this factored form is in fact equal to
the expression we started out with. Awesome.